China has reached an inflection point
the seemingly limitless wave of cheap
labour that helped propel the
extraordinary boom in its economy since
the early 1980s is coming to an end
the movement of peasant farmers from the
Chinese countryside to the cities over
the past thirty years isn't just the
biggest human exodus in history
it's the biggest migration of any type
of mammal
this phenomenon has created 250 cities
with more than 2 million people that's
equivalent to 88 London's but now the
migrant miracle is ending as the country
hits what's known as the lowest turning
point that's the moment when the flow of
people to the cities dries up and the
demographic and productivity dividend
slows and goes into reverse the most
obvious sign this is happening is the
fact
Everage wages for migrant workers have
more than doubled over the past seven
years
this suggests a mismatch between supply
and demand for low-skilled workers and
this contradiction is only going to get
worse
China is aging rapidly and just as
migrants are returning to their villages
this doesn't just mean the demise of the
economic growth model that has served
the country so well until now it also
has huge implications for a global
economy that relies on China to
manufacture its daily essentials but
this isn't just a macroeconomic story
the effects are being felt every day by
the millions of individuals who make up
the wave of humanity that has fueled the
Chinese economy young jeongyeol was a
first generation migrant worker one of
the hundreds of millions of people who
moved from the countryside to work in a
factory in one of China's growing
manufacturing centers with his monthly
salary he supports three generations of
family members
now he's considering making the journey
back to his home village for good
I mean de anza oh la la soon eh as I
tell it was a cool dog
he's a about teenagers Abajo constitutes
hi ho
yeah she's a terrier tell the attorneys
in the control to say to him I said you
there who Superman it seems I'm sure you
come Thomas has a cold yeah mmm
that's all one reader or missile
decently DeShazo sahaja Mormons ejection
keys in you can hold 20 second column
totals about Minnesota Maga Oh City and
Yamaha chancel concerts we also call it
a tibia since her champagne
Cinco de koning console Sangha community
today just one nya punch here now a tad
sweet so juicy totalmente pick a room in
the sofa uses or tokens constituting
poochishita toss to share poppy
Syria chozo chair consultation today
constituency i'ii go Sanjana 97
Association Panchen Draco funds are
today so to Busan upper silesia della
paura sucia
so what Chico you share intestines are
some common Japan Telecom want a better
condition Canadian version of
socialization sure Feeny yes so tiny
what is she watching supplements model
not hit different Department photoshoot
so you have inches
that's another concession auntie Hughes
until you pigeon a facet are not
appreciative
keep it up the security comes away so
much about pooja body so you put
something a volunteer so yeah hey Maya
Angelou for things appear after the
committed Colin Todd and yelling and
another injustice Oh Quentin Jesus Eddie
she's utility Mussoorie he also a
condition upon yeah omen and Tsubasa
the knife is really concerning her
charity protecting I share the opinion
then you Yoshi suit how you your satiety
how you your contour cheese on celibacy
so you want is a one also says no Linda
Yemen solidify inches episode Susan in
Tosa no tsunami get $40 she went la
jolla t na hito GA kimi GA fuku the same
one she's a ginger sued Emma
he called insider to be given resolution
me driving to her about the same
Australia sunny location really
delicious recipe she didn't do it
bueno ja da da da da do da ha ha Khalil
a qui tam o Geer - so you go to Turkey
he also said today the high rises over
the wounds on Tomas and what we attach a
by uniting with others also much
Sotomayor followed me so it's a new
phone system kappa ching get I can be
Baba you even get you totally should
solve so let's hold Jojo
je ne huachipa star woman some were
proficient and just concerned I use the
additive it's even too soon additional
personnel studied angry memory which I
had to come back that's all
she's a young catcher the sham Virginia
we should a dancer usually itching me
how you get to it achievements Italian
inside mr. Acharya you take another cell
phone Alicia I are Chinese an idea an
idea when you go sweetie Tendo my coma
isn't changing teachers in a team that's
original to teaching you constantly
changing me about you first one which is
such isn't she - the quenching over each
other
Shannon touchet out to do the job I love
you forever
she's here who does you know sister
Cinque Terre
tada
across China the factories that power
the country's growth for decades are
being squeezed by a shortage of workers
rising wages and falling prices
overcapacity and weak global demand have
led to four years of factory gate
deflation and many companies are
struggling to stay afloat
in our area more and more factories
closed down in the past there is not
much left I think it has to do a lot
with yeah the orders are not coming in
that are basically the economic growth
is not there as it used to be it's
getting more and more harder for people
to find shops the people the retention
rate remains higher the recent economic
downturn shows us very clearly that
brands do have to chase the cheap needle
so they're moving toward Southeast Asia
what remains in China is the fairly
complicated small volume business with
such uncertainty in China many companies
are relocating their manufacturing to
places like Vietnam but Vietnam is much
poorer and at a much earlier stage in
its industrialization than its giant
neighbor the gap is so great that some
Chinese firms are resorting to the
unthinkable importing workers
: Kochi de toda
yo Kanye Nascimento dejado nananana need
a Toshiya cuando yo gayben Chadha Yasui
Lyla
Harve Ann Hui worked in China illegally
but the long hours and distance from his
aging parents made him eventually return
to Vietnam
Dana we teach at some time I mean they
do some low fonyód Bigfoot Reena down um
I need to be on my own computer so my
bad not nice WH to quote plan hojae o
mundo kami Sunday lamb come a-knockin
Oklahoma knew mom would chop me lamb me
too quirky of hands at the pan young
with namu Amida you know mean vehicle is
out that sound webinar let's take
sangwich equipment may be gloomy to
Padma can mimic Lenora movie nano Roy
Valerie melamine might hit me a
technique on my team Chico Kyla Tarzan
Lambie
now that we had to you who can we can
win tamil meghna Birla whole kumbaya
America a [ __ ] been rollin come here for
me yet nylon una pajara nickel kid me
what is on Hamra mucho I can t even me
so challenged amid the hustle Zuko's
energy auditor if incident mochi so come
to the ampere too cheap it's a salute oh
um initiate the judge the chiku you know
yet older your engine temp in Baghdad
sorry good license in a bit hostage in
Sonia Sonia Singh ji so you and I get
all the know mingle vitiates a fashion
top of Archana 110 I was missing chain
tassel talk we need a beautifully
tailored songy your teeth of the tunnels
only marriages on the hostages as a Teja
wasn't sorry means yeah you - a cheater
so almost a year kaio-sama for Sandia my
cosmos ampere for the just yoyo venture
Saratoga Picasa
Hanapepe he comes our new senior GUI
Jesus huh when I just
father has to hang on
Suresh inhale you saw your Jetta
Virginia horses I have missing here
Hoshi have you taken your cuddle
citizens really kidding quiet Shinji
FinTech I see so we either choose all
inside not be seen seen Abby come so
don't have to say AHA so you get you
added a simple types of data cringy
chemically identical it starts on the
family which I hustle machine
the movement of Chinese people from
villages to the cities has helped
produce one of the biggest wealth
explosions ever seen other countries
with large rural populations are hoping
they can replicate China
India with 863 million rural dwellers
may eventually take the title as
workshop to the world but before that
the end of China's migrant miracle is
expected to see it slowed even more with
serious implications for the global
economy countries that have relied on
China's insatiable demand for raw
materials are facing a crisis China is
so important to commodity exporting
countries that even the suggestion of
falling Chinese demand has crushed
commodity prices and forced some
economies into recession
if the slowdown continues it could push
the whole world into a fresh economic
crisis even if that doesn't happen
continuously rising labor costs will
mean that consumers will have to pay
more for everything
in China
you
you